at least 17 people have been killed and
two explosions at a police station in
Northwest Pakistan more than 60 people
have been injured an offshoot of the
group tahriki Taliban Pakistan claimed
responsibility for the attack but local
police say the blasts were caused by
electrical shorts
come on Haider joins us now live from
Islamabad so authorities now saying
there was no attack at all involved in
these explosions
absolutely all night all the media
Outlets were reporting even from the
local area that this was an ongoing
attack that started after 15 GMT last
night however the Inspector General of
police issued a statement from the site
he said that number one there are two
main entrance gates to this compound
where the counter-terrorism department
facility is located he said there was no
signs of a forced entry or engagement
with any infiltrators this particular
building that we see that has been
extensively damaged in fact a couple of
buildings extensively damaged are about
300 meters inside the gate so that would
also suggest that there was no
infiltration that is what the Inspector
General of police is saying he said that
there were explosives a rocket-propelled
grenades that was stored at the facility
a number of detainees were also present
there five of whom are said to have been
killed in the blast he said that number
one there's no crater outside we would
suggest that a vehicle packed with
explosives would be able to penetrate
and then detonate the device he said
there was possibly an electrical short
circuit which led to those explosives
going off they were kept in a safe room
on the first floor of the
counter-terrorism department building he
said that after that there was a
secondary blast possibly a number of
smaller blocks he said that one of the
projectiles penetrated the adjoining
building from the top which would of
course indicate that these were the
secondary explosions going off after
that initial explosion in that room so
the police not confirming that this was
a terrorist attack they're saying this
is an accident that had happened
possibly inside but the people in swat
of course are not going to buy that
because they've already announced that
they will be coming out in strength to
protest against the return of the city
Taliban Pakistan Taliban Pakistan itself
had not issued any statement although an
unknown group calling itself the jihadia
Pakistan previously unknown claimed
responsibility for this particular
incident all right thanks so much come
on hither